- So, I have a Pomeranian.
His name is Jax.
14 years ago, I thought I was
going to lose him forever.
So, he was a puppy, I was a little kid,
and we were taking a road trip.
My parents were driving.
I was staying in the backseat.
His head was out the window.
The wind was blowing through his hair,
and then suddenly, the wind
just carried him out the window.
Oh my god, Jax!
I thought my dog was gone.
And I don't know if you've ever,
if you ever seen that movie White Chicks,
it was pretty much like literally
like that scene in that movie.
At this point, I'm crying.
My mom is screaming.
My dad's trying not to crash the car.
But it turned out he
was still on his leash,
and I look outside, Jax is just loving it.
I'm holding onto his leash,
and he's just smiling the whole time
as the wind is blowing
against the side of the car.
If I wasn't holding onto
him, he would've been gone.
I managed to reel him back in.
He made it back safely.
He didn't even realize that
he was in so much danger.
Even though he's a lot bigger
now, super protective of him.
If your dog is one pound and
he's staring out the window,
hold onto him, please.
(giggles)
(cheerful music)
(swooshing)